so I have this yellow rectangle here and
we know two things about this yellow
rectangle we know that it has a length
of 10 that the length of this side right
over here is 10 and we also know that
this yellow rectangle has an area of 60
square units whatever units were
measuring this 10 in so what I want you
to do is now pause this video and based
on the information given on these other
rectangles so in some of them we give
you two of their dimensions and some of
them we give you something like the
perimeter and one of the dimensions I
want you to pause the video and think
about which of these rectangles if any
of them have either the same area or the
same perimeter as this yellow rectangle
so pause the video right now well the
best way to figure out which of these
have the same area or perimeter as this
original yellow rectangle is to just
figure out the area in the perimeter for
all of these rectangles and see which
ones of them are equivalent so we
already know the area for this one but
we we don't know its perimeter so how do
we figure that out well to figure out
perimeter we would need to know the
lengths of all the sides well if the
area is 60 square units that means the
length times the width is equal to 60
that 10 times this length or dimes this
width right over here is going to be
equal to 60 so 10 times what is equal to
60 well 10 times 6 is equal to 60 10
times 6 is equal to 60 square units 10
units times 6 units is equal to 60
square units fair enough so how do we
figure out the perimeter now
well this is a rectangle so we know if
this length is 10 then this length must
also be 10 and if this width is 6 then
this width must be 6 as well and now we
can figure out the perimeter it's 10
plus 10 plus 6 plus 6 which is 32 so let
me write that down
the perimeter the perimeter of our
original yellow rectangle is equal to 32
now let's go on to each of these other
rectangles and figure out what their
perimeters and the areas are we already
know the perimeter for this purple or
move rectangle but we need to figure out
its area in order to figure out the area
we
can't just rely on this one dimension
just on its width we have to figure out
its length as well so how do we figure
that out well one way to realize it is
that the perimeter is the distance all
the way around the rectangle so what
would be the distance halfway around the
rectangle so let me see if I can draw it
so what would it be the distance of this
side this side our length Plus this side
well it would be half the perimeter five
plus something is going to be equal to
half the perimeter over the perimeter is
all four sides if we just took these two
sides which would be half the perimeter
so these two sides must be equal to when
you take their sum must be equal to 17
half the perimeter so five plus what is
equal to 17 five plus this question mark
is equal to 17 well five plus 12 is
equal to 17 and you can verify this 12
plus 5 is 17 and then that times two
gets us the perimeter of 34 now given
that what is the area of this figure
well the area is going to be twelve
units times five units to get sixty
square units
area is equal to sixty so this one right
over here has the same area different
perimeter same area as the original as
the original yellow rectangle different
area now let's go over here so I have
and this is not just a rectangle this is
also a square because I have the same
length and the same width so what's the
area here well for the area I just have
to multiply the length times the width
eight units times eight units is 64
square units and what is the perimeter
here what is the perimeter well these
two sides are going to make up half the
perimeter if I wanted to figure out the
whole one I know this is also eight and
this is also eight so the perimeter is
eight times four eight times four sides
which is equal to 32 so this square
right over here has a different area but
it has the same perimeter as our
original as our original yellow square
now let's move on to this blue one
what's the area and you're probably
getting used to this 15 units times four
units is going to be 60 square units and
what's the perimeter what's the
perimeter well it's going to be 4 plus
15 and whatever that is times 2 4 plus
15 is 19 and then 19 times 2 is 38 so
this one right here has the same area
different perimeter as our original now
finally here in purple what is the area
the area is 10 times 20 which is equal
to 200 so if it's 10 say well 10 units
times 20 units is 20 square 200 square
units and what is the perimeter what is
the perimeter well 10 plus 20 is 30 but
I've just considered only two of the
sides two of the sides right here that's
only half way around so 10 plus 20 is 30
times 2 is 60 so let's see this has a
different area and it also has a
different perimeter this this one's
perimeter looks just like the same it's
the same numbered 60 as the area here
but that's not what we're comparing we
have a different perimeter and different
areas so neither of these are the same
as our original rectangle